I've said before that there's no
category of devil fruits more hype than
mythical Zone fruits but I may have been
mistaken since arguably awakened fruits
are even more hype let me know what you
think by the end of the video in the
comments and today we'll be discussing
all 14 awakened devil fruits in one
piece so make sure to stay tuned for
that each other parking within and smash
that like button if you enjoy these
longer one piece videos and want to keep
them coming make this the video you
joined in outcome if you haven't already
by subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell so you don't miss
future one piece videos and updates and
you're also helping us achieve our crazy
dream of hitting 2 million subscribers
on YouTube so I'd be eternally grateful
for that and now without further Ado
let's jump into this the hypest of One
Piece topics spoilers and all so perhaps
the least interesting of the Awakenings
are the Jailer beasts that impel down
since they sort of just shot them
together and they sort of just
oversimplified slash under hyped what we
could expect from Zone Awakenings
thankfully not all Zone Awakenings are
like theirs or else some of the later
Awakenings will discuss what have been
more boring and less hype as we'll get
into in the case of the jail obese The
Zone Awakenings came with the innate
nature of the Zone while consuming the
user's personality so yeah they gained
extreme physical power but also became
simple-minded man beasts not very hype
crocodile mentioned that as awakened
Zone types their greatest strength is
their toughness and Recovery speed the
middle Taurus we're told is pretty much
an awakened cow fruit user even if a
Minotaur in mythology is a half bull
half man now keep in mind we didn't get
the exact names of these fruits from Oda
yet Luffy can't help but remarking that
the minotaurus sure is fast it's
explained that minotaurus is a
cold-blooded demon guard a monster that
tosses people like trash and the height
difference compared to Luffy is huge
this thing is buff and gigantic it
carries around a spike Club too as a
weapon gear second Luffy can send the
Beast flying and they're not the main
bad guys to fear during this Prison
Break Arc but as mindless strong and
fast monsters they do have a scary
Presence at least initially still
despite being awakened zones whereas
Luffy is nowhere near Awakening at this
point they just aren't that strong
relatively speaking Mino koala the
awaken koala Beast Mino rhinoceros the
awakened rhinoceros beast and Mino zebra
the awakened zebra Beast all get easily
wrecked by the combined forces of Luffy
jimbei and crocodile a star-sided group
to lose to for sure but again not really
serving to Hype up the potential of
Awakenings notably Amino rhinoceros
carries two Spike clubs minnow koala
Spike Knuckles and Mino zebra a spiked
ball at the end of a long shaft not that
these weapons do them much good so when
looking at these Awakenings Awakenings
seem kind of underwhelming especially
zones since you can't really picture
there being a main antagonist who is
just Mindless and yes the payoff of
super strength and speed is cool but
definitely not cool enough if they can
be easily dealt with by non-awakened
characters but never fear Awakenings
including Zone Awakenings get much more
hype as the series goes on WE thankfully
find out that zone Awakenings don't have
have to come with the loss of
Personality or complex thinking and we
learned that first when Luffy awakens
his mythical sun god Nika fruit but
let's first discuss Kaku and Rob luchi's
Awakenings and save Luffy the best
awakened zone for last now this is
probably clear by now but obviously it
seems like the stronger a character is
before Awakening the stronger they'll
power boost will be when Awakening comes
not all awakened users are equal in
strength as is obvious when you see a
Gear 2 Luffy take down an awakened Zone
without much trouble these next
Awakenings happen to already
considerably strong characters which
inevitably make them more hype so let's
start with Kaku who ate the aux fruit
model giraffe and became a giraffe human
now his giraffe Awakening didn't make me
think he could handle Zoro obviously in
chapter 1072 but it was still cool to
see we see that he like Luchi has a sort
of dark cloud floating around his neck
like the white one that floats around
Luffy's at first kaku's nose pistol
pushes Zorro back who blocks it with his
swords the attack is drill like as his
long neck swirls behind the head but
props to his Armament hockey you know
it's on point when you can attack swords
with your nose he can then move into
kiriman gyro meaning giraffe man snake
rotation where he rapidly rotates
creating cutting wind slashes similar to
kaido Zoro acts more annoyed than
challenge though saying he just fought
plenty of Wrigley things at wano and at
this point he's getting tired he pushes
Kaku back sending his head smashing into
his surroundings now Zoro doesn't just
beat Kaku here with an unnamed attack
but the fight does end with Stussy
taking him out with a vampire-like sneak
attack awakened Kaku passes out before
Zoro can use significant named attacks
on him or really try for that matter but
chances are he wouldn't have put up much
of a fight against Zoro at this point
anyways and that's further supported by
the fact that in the manga as of writing
Zoro was paired with Rob Luchi in battle
while Luffy is paired with kisaru which
seems like a much better matchup for the
new Zorro next we see Luffy freeing a
captured Luchi and Kaku to help them
against the seraphims probably not the
smartest move but it lets us see more of
these two in action and Kaku uses
Tempest kick white thunder in unison
with zoro's Purgatory onigiri to send
little mihawk flying back his attack
Tempest kick Slaughter is paired up with
Zorro's one sword style eie deathline
song but it's still not enough to keep
s-hawk down but luckily Zorro finally
realizes that these dudes have
similarities to lanerians and he warns
them to watch it since their attacks
won't do any damage unless the Flames
are out we later see that these guys did
beat the seraphim and then took York the
traitor Punk hostage what's shocking is
afterwards they gave Luchi enough
freedom to take out Stussy once he saw
that kizuru was here but Sanji quickly
dealt with an injured Kaku by trapping
him in a sea Stone bubble clearly Kaku
is not treated by Oda as a formidable
opponent awaken giraffe or not however
Oda does see fit to let Zorro and Luchi
Clash so that brings us to Luchi who
recently awakened the Neko Neko no me
model leopard aka the cat cat fruit
model leopard understandably luchi's
Awakening gets more screen time than
kaku's since he's stronger and the main
antagonist of their group he also has
the dark fiery clouds around his
awakened form and at the end of his tale
which almost makes me want to assume
that these fiery Cloud looking things
accompanies our Awakenings where the
user maintains their will and
personality perhaps your will has to be
especially strong to experience this
kind of Zone Awakening versus the lose
your personality kind Luffy and Lucy
proceed to go at it Luchi more serious
and gear 5 Luffy mostly looking like
he's just having fun as with Kaku these
non-methical Zone Awakenings obviously
increase your speed power and durability
but you don't see crazy new abilities
like we're going to see with Luffy in
this form Luchi is strong enough to do a
hockey fist clash with Luffy I'll give
credit words to and luchi's sharp hockey
Laden awakened claws are able to get to
Santa motto and take him down what's
more he's fast enough to do this without
Luffy or santamaru stopping him however
Santo Maru does say he saw him coming
and blocked the attack it just looks
like Luchi still got through the
impressive defensive power of sento Maru
which is considerable praise in and of
itself Luffy ends the battle by hitting
Luchi with a dawn rocket luchikov's
blood and he asks himself where is the
new yonko getting so much force then
Luffy makes it to the leaving vacuum
rocket without Luchi being able to stop
him so clearly Luffy came out on top in
that exchange and most recently you got
Zorro taking on Luchi saying with this
level of power there's no way Zoro will
let him fight the captain and Luchi says
maybe you're right I think it will be
worthwhile to kill the number two of an
emperor and that's not only useful for
showing that yeah awaken Luchi is
obviously not Luffy level but it's also
cool how he's seen enough now to
acknowledge the straw hats as a yonko
crew because he was reluctant to do that
before but clearly they earned his
respect now all in all these
non-mythical Awakenings are pretty
straightforward where they gain
empowered defense endurance and speed
and the ones that kept their
personalities intact after Awakening all
also have the distinctive fiery clouds
floating around them in their awakened
forms but of course Luffy's mythical
Zone Awakening is much less
straightforward and because of that a
lot more fun to talk about so as those
of us caught up with the manga or anime
know by now Luffy recently awakened his
and it turns out the name was a cover he
actually has the mythical Zone sun god
Nika fruit in other words the
gomgomunomi is actually not a paramecia
rubber fruit but a mythical Zone fruit
its actual names the human human fruit
mythical model Nika and Nika was a sun
god associated with Liberation his hair
looks like it's made out of flames and
turns white in this form and the rest of
his outfit turns mostly white too of
course there is also the fiery Cloud we
saw with luchin Kaku but in this case
it's white not dark Luffy calls this
awakened form gear 5 and I gotta say it
is reminiscent of the Super Saiyan form
with the light-colored hair standing up
like that but that only makes a cool
homage to Dragon Ball and doesn't take
away from the hype at all as far as we
know this is the only fruit that was so
dangerous and special that the
government changed its name It's
associated with the sun god Nika with
joy boy and now with our main character
and the last time it awakened was more
than 800 years ago so since then the
users before Luffy only got to the
rubber stage of it that's a nice little
aspect to it because yeah Luffy still
has a super special fruit but at least
he had to work hard in order to unlock
its specialness many others could have
had this Godly fruit and never gotten to
this point the five Elders further
explained that they attempted to get the
sun god fruit for 800 years and not once
that they succeed it actively tried to
escape their grasp and that type of
personification makes sense because
specifically Zone fruits are said to
contain a will of their own this
suggests that the fruit probably picked
Luffy similarly to how I believe
Yamato's fruit probably picked her it
wasn't just Luffy happening to eat it it
probably called out to him on some level
and I think the Netflix adaptation
actually made that even more clear so
what are some of the properties of this
God fruit we know the rubber fruit but
it's explained that after awake
thickening the rubbery body of the user
gains greater physical strength and
freedom it is said by the five Elders
that there is no power more ridiculous
and in the official translation we are
given not one but two exclamation marks
it's portrayed as the biggest deal and
for good reason it's also mentioned that
the rubbery body lets the user fight in
whatever way he fancies bringing smiles
to the faces of the people another name
for the sun god Nika we're told is also
the warrior of Liberation now that's a
big deal the quote saying that the user
of the fruit can fight in whatever way
they fancy it seems to imply that Luffy
is only limited by his imagination when
it comes to the way in which he fights
and the powers which he manifests I
won't go so far as to say he can do
anything yet because some of this might
be more Legend than truth but it'll be
interesting to see how accurate the
description is as the story progresses
and Luffy continues to use his new
awakened Powers so far we've seen crazy
stuff like Luffy using his awakened
fruit to grab kaido's giant dragon form
like he was a mere Snake toy and pull
him up to at a roof he proceeded to
practically enter a tune world he spun
kaido around and slammed him into the
ground over and over again kaido's eyes
pop out like in the Looney Tunes
cartoons suggesting that Luffy can make
his opponents take on these exaggerated
characteristics not just himself we also
see Luffy pull a Popeye and summon
massive muscles all of a sudden I mean
if he is strong enough to lift kaido
like this I doubt there's any opponent
he can't lift he also rubberized the
ground and lifted it up to deflect a
blast breath showing his awakened powers
can definitely affect his surroundings
not just other characters or himself he
then caught lightning and threw it like
Zeus himself and flew by running through
the air like in the old cartoons perhaps
the most absurd thing is when he entered
kaido's body and pushed his hands out of
kaido's eyes so that he had a pair of
dragon eyeball gloves as the eyeball
stretched with Luffy's arms he also
punched through kaido's head but
ironically Luffy's awakened Powers
seemed to protect kaido in a sense at
times because one would assume his
eyeballs wouldn't survive and his head
wouldn't survive if he didn't become
stretchy and cartoonish because of
Luffy's awakened influence on him he
used this Awakening of course his
battery over hockey to beat the
so-called strongest creature in the
world and the living yako with the
highest Bounty at the time we talked
about the lucify 2 and in this fight he
made his head big enough to almost eat
the awakened Luchi he also finished the
fight by making a surrounding tube
stretchy and flinging himself from it
and into Luchi his Dawn rocket stretches
Lucy to an insane degree showing again
that Luffy's Powers influenced Luchi
just like they did kaido most recently
we saw awake and Luffy vs kizuru he uses
his power to magnify his size and uses
his gigantic hand to pick up the Admiral
at the end of chapter 1092. in the next
chapter Luffy takes in a light beam
designed to stop the Vega tank pretty
impressive Luffy just says the attack is
hot but still he appears to have tanked
that Admiral attack in cartoonish
fashion like a champ and that's just
some of the cartooner stuff we've seen
from Luffy clearly his Awakening has
much more fun possibilities than the
other awakened zones we've seen it's
very very versatile and I put my money
on him rather than on kizaru at this
point if it doesn't end in an escape
instead if you notice Luffy's Awakening
allowed him to change himself like a
Zone but also his surroundings like the
other paramecia Awakenings we are about
to get into making it very special
indeed and it makes sense why shanks's
crew took that one specifically from the
world government not to mention Luffy's
fruit can even have an effect on his
opponents and not just an inanimate
objects definitely ridiculous and a
unique power next let's look at the
paramecia Awakenings I mentioned first
let's look at Don Quixote doflamengo he
awakened the Ito Ito no me aka the
string string fruit in order to become a
string human very Spider-Man like it as
qualities as with other paramecia The
Awakening allows the user to affect the
surrounding area like the ground or
buildings in this case though Flamingo
can turn them into Strings which he can
then use to enhance his attack or
defense in one case he turns the
surrounding ground to Strings and then
brings them up to block gear 4 Luffy's
attack he then proceeds to turn
surrounding buildings in into Strings
and Luffy is shocked saying it's almost
like he isn't a paramecia and let's give
Oda comedic points for that now looking
back because Luffy actually was the one
who wasn't a paramecium doflamingo uses
the strings of the buildings and
elsewhere to send spikes of strings at
Luffy at one point but Luffy is able to
break through and land a hit the tie
turns when Luffy runs out of gear for
steam but when the fight starts again
it's crazy to see doflamingo use ever
white to turn the entire town into
Strings and the strings now below Luffy
wrap around him definitely a scary power
but in the end Luffy's gear 4 punches
through doflamingo's strings and with
gum gum gong he delivers a finishing
blow although it's cool to see
doflamingo create a spider web of
strength to protect himself it's clearly
not as effective if the opponent is
strong enough to punch through it so
although this was already pretty obvious
with the Jailer beasts again we see that
although Awakening can be cool very cool
in fact it doesn't mean that a
non-awakened devil fruit user isn't
stronger a gear 4 Luffy beat awakened
doflamango and in Luffy's case awakened
gear 5 is way way stronger and that
makes sense too because as kaido said to
Luffy hockey is the key to ruling the
Seas and that's how Roger was able to do
it without any devil fruit at all in the
end it was Luffy's hockey Mastery that
allowed him to finish off kaido's
flaming Dragon form without being burnt
The Awakening alone wouldn't have been
enough so as we're enjoying how fun
these devil fruit powers are we just
have to keep in mind that it'll never be
the fruit that makes the man awakened or
not next up is Charlotte katakuri who
awakened the mochi mochi no me a special
paramecia named after the Japanese
Confections even that special adjective
in front of the paramecia title makes it
a very unique and intriguing fruit as
we'll get into the user can usually
create control and turn their body parts
into Mochi this material can be like a
liquid and easily malleable but it can
also be hardened it's sticky and can
trap people but as jimbe explains you
can escape it if there's enough moisture
the whole being able to turn your body
into Mochi is similar to a logia and
that's special about this fruit because
you'll remember even after Awakening
doflamingo can't turn himself into
Strings and thus Dodge physical attacks
like a logia so with all these Powers
already what is katakuri's Awakening
well it's like doflamingos in a sense
that it allows him to turn surrounding
inorganic material into Mochi in one
case he turns the ground below Luffy's
feet into Mochi as well his awakened
devil fruit helped karakuri reach a
1.057 billion Berry Bounty and even
though now we know that Luffy's fruit is
the Nika fruit and in fact Superior to
katakuris at the time karakuri's fruit
was portrayed as a superior version of
Luffy's gum gum fruit he could extend
his limbs like rubber but also act like
a logia and it was awakened to boot and
not related to the fruit but karakuri
even had future sight which let him see
into the future so in the beginning it
definitely didn't look like Luffy would
win but Luffy's gear for Snake Man form
his growth during the battle his refusal
to say down along with the
psychologically shaken state of karakuri
allowed Luffy to be the last man
standing this battle that on paper
karakuri should have won going in into
it is a great Testament to the
importance of willpower and maybe even a
nod to the fact that Luffy would turn
out to be a mythical Zone because of
that insane level of durability next
let's turn to a dude who was used by Oda
as an offering to the one-piece fandom's
God Shanks of course I speak of Captain
Eustis kid I'll admit I like kid I
wanted to see more of him but you just
can't help a guy that keeps going after
Shanks and his crew without ever
learning his lesson luckily at least we
did get to see the awakened power that
helped him reach 3 billion berries and
defeat big mom before Shanks ended his
whole career and crew so kid awakened
the jiki jiki no me aka the Magna magnet
fruit the paramecia allowed him to
create magnetic forces and thus to
control metal he could attract and repel
metallic objects which is very useful in
a world where people fight with swords
guns and cannonballs there's just
something so cool about watching a dude
stop a cannonball in midair and then
send it back at the enemy we know he can
use metallic objects to form normal or
even gigantic metallic limbs which he
can use in battle in one case he grabbed
big mom with his metallic arm and then
repelled his arm in order to send even
big mom flying despite her massive size
and strength now the weakness is that if
there's no metallic objects nearby the
power is kind of useless until you
awaken it that is both kid and law said
their Awakenings consumed a lot of
stamina during the big mom fight but
they use it nonetheless as a last resort
against big mom kids allows him to
assign magnetic qualities to something
or someone in other words he can assign
magnetic qualities to big mom and have
her attract all the surrounding metal
until it slams into her and buries her
or not using any metal he can assign a
specific polarity to big mom and then
the opposite polarity to a wall or
something else so she can separate from
it one of kids coolest abilities though
is definitely damned Punk AKA
electromagnetic cannon that lets him use
metal to create an enormous railgun
which he can then fire at his opponent
it generates enough Force to push big
mom off avonigashima we see from
shanks's advanced future site that kid's
damned Punk was going to charge and fire
multiple shots destroying shanks's
Allied ships to credit kids power Shanks
does look very concerned and says he's
about to do some serious damage he looks
great and Beckman says it sounds like
you've seen a hell of a future but
Shanks being the overpowered Yoko he is
finishes kid before the railgun can ever
be fired off in other words the battle
is over before it even started and then
braggy and Dory destroy what's left of
the ship and the narrator tells us in a
matter of seconds Shanks just completely
eradicated This Crew so yeah kids career
seems to have been cut short awakened or
not and again we're reminded that hockey
and not devil fruits rules the sea but
kid must get some props at least for how
much the power of His delford attacked
freaked out someone like Shanks next we
got Trafalgar D water law and the
opeopeno me aka the apop fruit La
parallel kid in so many ways he also
helped beat big mom with his awakened
Powers he also got a 3 billion Berry
Bounty and then he also lost toyanko
family Blackbeard but it arguably wasn't
as bad there was at least a fight and
law managed to be saved by sulong Beppo
even if his crew wasn't so lucky so what
is the Awakening of this paramecia fruit
that's been called the ultimate devil
fruit because of its power to Grant
another person Eternal youth in exchange
for the user's life the Marines at one
point were willing to pay 5 billion
berries for it and when you think about
how that's way more than even shanks's
Bounty I think you start to get a
picture of how important it is so lost
devil fruit allowed him to create a room
AKA a spherical space in which he can
manipulate anything or anyone he wants
he can split apart body parts make
people switch places and so on and so on
the limitation is that people including
law had to be inside the stationary
space for him to use this crazy ability
on them but his Awakening allows him to
make up for this limitation once
awakened locking creates special rooms
that wrap around objects or people and
he doesn't have to be inside these rooms
for him to operate AKA use his abilities
for instance with okay room or Chrome
however you want to say it he is able to
coat his sword in his abilities he can
then use anesthesia his sword can expand
and penetrate his Target without hurting
them but that's where moves like shock
Willey and puncture Willey come in law
releases electrical shock waves through
his sword that fried the target from the
inside in this way he can bypass the
strong outward defenses of his opponents
with puncture will a law extends the
sword way further than the target think
from flying onigashima all the way to
deep in the Earth the release shock
waves make big mom cough up blood and
also create a large deep crater in the
ground that they will later send big mom
into our room allows law to toss his
spherical space at a Target when
attached to big bomb it follows her and
lets law use his abilities on her even
from a distance for instance he makes
the r room silent so that big mom can't
give orders to her homies as she falls
deeper and deeper into the Earth as with
kid lost 3 billion Barry Bounty and
awakened devil fruit was not enough for
him to take down a yonko how however I
do think his awaken abilities are very
interesting potential wise and as a
result I'm glad he was saved Oda clearly
plans to expand on his powers and
abilities and the rest of his story and
now that he's not with his crew I think
him teaming up with the straw hats even
temporarily again would be the obvious
move and now we move to the non-canon
awakened devil fruits the ones that were
not in the manga and so did not take
place in the Canon story but sometimes
these are especially interesting in the
first case we got Guild Tesoro from One
Piece Film gold he ate the gorugoruno Mi
aka the gold gold fruit it's a non-canon
paramecia that allows the user to
manipulate gold we're talking changing
gold they touch from solid to liquid and
back easily one of the ways Guild made
this ability even more overpowered was
by stranding himself with his gold and
even sprinkling the people who entered
his casino with gold flakes as a result
if they tried anything he could use the
gold flakes to turn them into gold in
case statues even someone like Zorro was
a prisoner for most of the movie because
of this ability The Awakening is not
quite what you'd expect it's not like he
can turn non-gold surroundings into gold
rather The Awakening increases the
user's influence over their gold aka the
gold they touched allowing them to sense
the gold under their powers like a
complex sensory Network in other words
if someone tries to break through one of
his gold walls leading to a treasure for
example he will be able to detect when
and where it's happening and although
it's cool that you can create a giant
gold Mecca around yourself if you got
enough gold there are obvious weaknesses
for instance you can't create gold or
turn stuff into gold it's not the Midas
touch power unfortunately you need to
have gold around you need to have
touched it and if the goal touches
seawater then the effect is nullified
next we have Douglas bullet from One
Piece Stampede he was called the demon
Heir and served under Roger the king of
the Pirates his strength back in the day
was compared in the film to that of
prime silver Israeli Roger's right-hand
man and since the dude is 45 and kept up
his training for becoming the strongest
you can only imagine how strong he is by
this point in the movie he even takes on
the many Supernova present at the same
time at one point without his devil
fruit powers and wrecks them for the
most part making them look very bad by
comparison he ate the gashagasha know me
aka the Clank Clank fruit and became an
assimilation human this non-canon
paramecia allows the user to assimilate
or combine different things together The
Awakening allows the user to combine
things to an insane extent without
relying on touch the user can draw on
the surrounding environment like houses
or even opponents ships and he can use
them to create what I must again call a
giant Mecca looks like the one piece
movies love Giant mechas in this case
the mecca is just made from the breaking
down and then assimilation of many
different materials rather than just
from gold this enormous assimilated
Mecca can split an island with a punch
that's how powerful it is Douglas bullet
also has impressive hockey so it's not
just the devil fruit that he has going
for him it took both garps and Goku and
more to stop him in the past but in this
case gear 4 Luffy manages to win with
some help from some big names like Sabo
boa and so on is it a believable Victory
probably not after how much they hyped a
bullet in this movie but does it really
matter in a non-canon story when the
music is so hype maybe that's a more
important question to ask ourselves
while watching these movies the last
non-canon awakened fruit is the Ute no
me this non-canon paramecia fruit allows
its user to turn anything into a gun
turning them into a firing human it was
eaten by bad one Gracie in the one piece
Premiere show 2017 a live show that was
performed at Universal Studios Japan's
Water World stage from June 30th to
October 1st since it's like
non-non-canon at this point they went
pretty crazy with this fruit the
awakened user can turn surrounding areas
or surfaces into Firearms like guns or
cannons including an entire island or
even the sea in the end Luffy wins with
Redhawk because why not but man did they
get creative with this one now to
clarify those are all the confirmed
awakened devil fruits but that doesn't
mean there aren't other awakened fruits
in the series it could be that they just
haven't been confirmed yet for instance
one that's probably awakened is Mino
Chihuahua a new Jailer Beast we saw in a
cover story and based on his appearance
and what we know from the other Jailer
beasts he probably is an awakened
Chihuahua but since it's only likely to
be the case and hasn't been confirmed I
didn't want to count him in the title
then you can really start to speculate
about the others too like if kaido is
already awakened and he actually started
out as a Magikarp before he awakened
into a Gyarados AKA Azure dragon or you
can speculate about Blackbeard Awakening
the dark dark fruit and that's why it's
so different from other logias as Ace
noticed way back when but anyways you
get my point there could be other
Awakenings but speculating on those is
more so the topic for another video but
if you can't get enough of devil fruit
Powers you won't want to miss my all
mythical zones and their powers
explained video link on screen right now
I even rank them in this one like And
subscribe to help us reach our insane
goal of 2 million subscribers on YouTube
and I'll see you in the next one